- We have witnessed history.
For the first time ever,
Congress has criminally
referred a former President
for criminal prosecution.
Even Nixon and Andrew
Johnson were never referred
to the Justice Department
for criminal prosecution.
But what does this mean?
What is a criminal referral?
And what was the January 6th Committee
basing its findings on?
Well,
throughout the January 6th
Committee's hearings this summer
and fall, Committee has presented evidence
of Donald Trump's attempt
to remain in power
despite tens of millions of
Americans, more importantly,
306 real members of the electoral college
which are more important than millions
of Americans saying no.
They've also presented
eyewitness testimony
and depositions about the way
that Trump's deranged insistence
the election had been
stolen resulted in an armed
and deadly insurrection
on the Capitol building.
The Committee interviewed
Georgia Secretary of State,
Brad Raffensperger, about
his perfect phone call
with Donald Trump.
Raffensperger testified that
Trump called him asking him
to find 11,000 ballots
to help flip Georgia
from its blue reality.
The Committee heard testimony
from a slew of White House
and other government officials
that they had told Trump
that his election denial stuff
was absolutely not correct.
But that Trump totally ignored
and disregarded their pleadings.
There was memorable testimony
from 26-year-old aide
to chief of staff Mark
Meadows, Cassidy Hutchinson,
who testified that Meadows suggested
he knew beforehand about the insurrection
that would happen on January 6th.
- I found Mr. Meadows in
his office on the couch.
I remember leaning against
the doorway and saying,
"I just had an interesting
conversation with Rudy, Mark.
Sounds like we're going
to go to the Capitol."
He didn't look up from his phone
and said "Things might get
real, real bad On January 6th."
- She also testified that Trump wanted
to give armed protestors entry
to where he was giving his speech,
so much so that he demanded
all metal detectors
or mags be removed from the area.
- He was angry
that we weren't letting
people through the mags
with weapons.
I overheard the President say
something as the effect of,
"Let my people in, they can
march the Capitol from here."
- Of course, there was
also the ketchup anecdote.
- I left the office and went
down to the dining room.
I first noticed there was
ketchup dripping down the wall
and there was a shattered porcelain plate.
The President was extremely angry
and had thrown his lunch against the wall.
- But in the final public hearing
of the January 6th
Committee, Bennie Thompson
and the other eight members
of the bipartisan group
laid out, arguably,
the most damning evidence
of both Trump's apathy
towards the 2020 Presidential election
and Trump's thundering
silence for 187 minutes
while insurrectionists
overran the Capitol.
Trump's White House
counsel, Pat Cipollone,
and Hope Hicks testified
to Trump's silence
during the insurrection.
- [Cheney] So, are you
aware of any phone call
by the President of the United States
to the Secretary of Defense that day?
- Not that I'm aware of, no.
- But make no mistake though,
Trump was definitely busy
strengthening his case
for section 1512 and 1505 obstruction.
- The President was making
phone calls that afternoon,
but they weren't to law
enforcement officials,
rather President Trump continued
to call his lawyer Rudy Giuliani.
Both President Trump
and Mr. Giuliani spoke
with congressional
leaders to encourage them
to continue delaying the session.
- Finally, the lawyers in the
Trump White House testified
about his Nixon-esque plot to
replace the Attorney general
with a brazen sycophant.
- President Trump tried
to install a loyalist named Jeffrey Clark
to lead the department as
Acting Attorney General.
- Now, that's just skimming
the surface for some
of the evidence that the
January 6th Committee unearthed
and presented in support of
their criminal referrals.
But what is a Congressional
criminal referral?
Well, a criminal referral
is a recommendation
from a congressional Committee
to the Justice Department
that, based on certain
evidence, the Committee believes
that people committed certain crimes.
When Congress makes a criminal referral,
it has no legal weight.
The Department of Justice does not have
to file criminal charges
just because Congress made a referral.
Congress makes law and the
executive branch enforces it.
But that doesn't mean that the referral is
just Congress handing the DOJ a thick file
and saying "Good luck."
It is, as we all know by now,
unprecedented for Congress
to say that a President committed crimes.
The Committee's recommendation
puts more pressure
on the Justice Department and
special prosecutor Jack Smith
to go forward with a prosecution.
And the special prosecutor
statute requires Smith
to explain the basis for
whatever action he takes,
including if he declines
to prosecute Trump.
But no doubt the Department
of Justice is going
to be less interested in
the ultimate recommendation
of Congress and more
interested in the evidence
that the Committee has gathered.
So let's talk about the criminal
referrals that were made
of former President Trump.
Representative Raskin said
that the four statutes
that are named here are not the only laws
that former President
Trump potentially violated,
but they are the most important ones.
The first is account of obstruction
of an official proceeding
under 18 USC 1512,
which makes it illegal
to corruptly obstruct
an official proceeding.
The Committee report concluded
that Congress' Joint Session
to count electoral votes
on January 6th was an official proceeding
under Section 1512, and the
report relies on the decisions
of the many federal judges
who have already reached this conclusion
in cases involving the
January 6th defendants.
As for whether Trump had
the requisite intent,
the Committee concluded that, quote,
"There should be no doubt
that President Trump knew
that his actions were likely to, quote,
'obstruct, influence or
impede that proceeding.'"
And based on the evidence developed,
President Trump was attempting to prevent
or delay the counting
of lawful certified
electoral college votes
from multiple states.
Quote, "President Trump was
directly and personally involved
in this effort,
personally pressuring Vice
President Pence relentlessly
as the Joint Session on
January 6th approached."
Quote, "Indeed, in an email
exchange during the violence
of January 6th, John Eastman admitted
that President Trump had been advised
that Vice President Pence
could not lawfully refuse
to count votes under
the Electoral Count Act,
but once he gets something in his head,
it's hard to get him to change course.
In addition, President Trump
knew that he had lost dozens
of state and federal lawsuits
and that the Justice
Department, his campaign,
and his other advisors concluded
that there was insufficient
fraud to alter the outcome.
President Trump also knew that no majority
of any State legislature had taken
or manifested any intention
to take any official action
that could change a State's
electoral college votes."
And the effort to pressure Mike Pence is
just one possible
violation of 18 USC 1512.
The Committee said that
there is also evidence
to support charges, quote,
"Based on the plan to create
and transmit to the executive
and legislative branches
fraudulent electoral slates,
which were ultimately intended
to facilitate an unlawful
action by Vice President Pence
to refuse to count legitimate
certified electoral votes
during Congress's official
January 6th proceeding."
In addition to the fake electoral slates,
the Committee found evidence
that Trump may have illegally pressured
state election officials,
state legislators,
and others to, quote, "Alter
official electoral outcomes."
And finally, the report
also says that Trump tried
to corrupt the Department of
Justice, citing his commitment
to the DOJ that all it
needed to do was, quote,
"Just say that the election was corrupt,
plus leave the rest to me and
the Republican congressmen."
The Committee also uncovered evidence
that Jeffrey Clark was
instrumental in trying
to corrupt the Department of Justice
and further into the scheme to interfere
with the official proceeding of Congress
to certify the vote.
- Jeffrey Clark was an
Assistant Attorney General,
a Trump appointee at the
Department of Justice.
According to multiple
sources, Mr. Clark was asked
by then President Trump
to take over the role
of Attorney General in part
so he could issue a series
of letters falsely suggesting
that the Department
of Justice believed the
Presidential election
may have been stolen.
Of course, this happened
after the department had
repeatedly informed President Trump
that his allegations of a
stolen election were not true
and were not supported by the evidence.
And this happened after
dozens of courts had ruled
against President Trump and
his election fraud claims.
- Clark sent the letter that
Cipollone described as, quote,
"A murder suicide pact" in
the hope that it would, quote,
"Help persuade a state legislature
to change its certified slate
of electoral college electors based
on false allegations of fraud."
Which was then supposed to inspire Pence
to count a different slate on January 6th.
And according to the Committee,
the letter was transparently
false, improper and illegal.
And in terms of the actual Capitol rights,
the Committee says that
Trump's action and inaction
during the January 6th
riot was more evidence
of intent to obstruct Congress.
He spent 187 minutes
refusing to take any step
to stop the violence.
And instead, Trump and Rudy
Giuliani called members
of Congress who were
sheltering in place to hide
from the attackers and
asked them to go along
with the illegal Eastman
plan and impede the vote.
And the Committee said that John Eastman
and Kenneth Chesebro were
instrumental in the conspiracy
and that representative Scott Perry
and other republicans who
have resisted testifying
likely have material facts
regarding Trump's plan
to overturn the election.
The second count of the
criminal referral deals
with conspiracy to
defraud the United States.
Section 371 of Title 18
makes it illegal to enter
into a criminal conspiracy
to defraud the United States.
The Supreme Court has held
that the statute criminalizes the use
of deceptive practices in
connection with any conspiracy
for the purpose of impairing, obstructing,
or defeating the lawful
function of any department
of government.
And conspiring to obstruct
a Joint Session of Congress
from certifying the
election certainly qualifies
as seeking to obstruct a lawful
function of the government.
And the Committee generally
alleges that Trump
and his co-conspirators
followed a seven point plan.
First, engage in a concerted effort
to spread false information
to the American public
that the 2020 election was stolen.
Second, to orchestrate a corrupt scheme
between Trump Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
and representative Scott Perry
to replace the acting Attorney General
who rejected Trump's fraud claims.
With Trump's DOJ ally Jeffrey Clark
to use the Department of Justice
to overturn the election.
Third, to implement Eastman's plan
to pressure Vice President
Pence to refuse to count
or delay the certification
of the electoral count.
Fourth, to pressure
state election officials
and state legislators to
change election results.
Fifth, to instruct Republicans
to create false electoral slates
in seven battleground states
and transmit those fake slates
to Congress and the National Archives.
Six, to summon up a mob in the US Capitol.
And seven, during the attack
on the Capitol to ignore pleas
for help and tacitly endorse the violence,
including threats to hang Mike Pence.
As for proof that
individuals use deceitful
or dishonest means, the Committee says
that there were two areas where Trump
and his friends were deceitful.
Starting with their insistence
the election was fraudulent
and that Trump defeated Joe Biden.
There's actually an
incredibly damning chart
on page 17 of the
Committee's report outlining
what the lawyers were saying
that there wasn't election fraud
versus what Trump was saying
that there was mass election fraud.
For example,
Trump showed then Deputy
Attorney General Jeffrey Rosen,
a videotape that supposedly
showed a suitcase full
of ballots.
Rosen explained to Trump that
this was actually, quote,
"A bin.
That's what they use when
their counting ballots.
It's benign."
One week later, Trump
repeated the conspiracy claim.
Quote, "There is even the
security camera footage
from Georgia that shows
officials telling poll watchers
to leave the room before
pulling suitcases of ballots out
from under the tables and
continuing to count for hours."
Attorney General Bill Barr
and Deputy AG Richard Donoghue
debunked Trump's Michigan
and Pennsylvania voter fraud claims.
But once again, Trump
ignored what they were saying
and made up his own facts.
Trump followed the same pattern
with other conspiracy theories
about Dominion voting machines.
And as to motive, the Committee
says that, first of all,
it helped Trump raise money and, quote,
"Evidence gathered by
the Committee indicates
that President Trump
raised roughly one quarter
of a billion dollars
in fundraising efforts
between the election and January 6th.
These solicitations persistently
claimed and referred
to the election fraud that did not exist."
And the second reason Trump
lied about election fraud was
to obstruct the January 6th
certification proceedings.
Quote, "Trump disregarded
the rulings of the courts
and rejected the findings and conclusions
and advice from his Justice
Department, his campaign experts
and his White House and Cabinet advisors.
He chose instead to try
to overturn the election
on January 6th and took a
series of very specific steps
to attempt to achieve that result."
And this is all related to the
third element of a conspiracy
that the person takes
at least one overt act
in furtherance of the conspiracy.
For Trump to achieve the desired result,
he had to get Mike Pence
to ignore the constitutional duties.
You might recall
that the 12th Amendment
gives the Vice President,
in their role as the President
of the Senate, the job
of certifying the results of
the Presidential election.
Quote, "The president of the
Senate shall, in the presence
of the Senate and the
House of Representatives,
open all of the certificates
and the votes shall then be counted.
The person having the
greatest number of votes
for President shall be the President."
The Electoral Count Act of 1887 reiterates
that the Vice President's
role is ministerial,
in that his job is just
to count the votes,
not to choose which votes to
count and which to reject.
But while Trump was being told
that he lost the election,
lawyer John Eastman and others, quote,
"Devised a plan whereby
Vice President Pence would,
as a presiding officer, declare
that certain electoral votes
from certain states could not be counted
at the Joint Session."
John Eastman knew before
proposing this plan
that it was was not legal.
Despite knowing that the plan was illegal,
Trump pursued it anyway including
for the 187 minutes when
the attack happened.
Congress was being evacuated
to underground tunnels
and even after he was aware
that the mob was chanting
about hanging Mike Pence.
Count three of the
criminal referral refers
to a conspiracy to make false
statements under 18 USC 1001.
This is the classic lying
to the government provision.
And this count was about Trump
conspiring with other people
to submit slates of fake
electors to Congress
and the National Archives.
These certificates were patently false
since Biden won each of those states
and the state's authorities
certified Biden's victory.
Now, in fairness, whether a
statement or act is material
for the purposes of Section
1001 can be a contentious issue,
but here the report says
that at best, quote,
"It can hardly be disputed
that the false slates
of electors were material as
nothing can be more material
to the Joint Session of
Congress to certify the election
than the question of which
candidate won which states.
Indeed, evidence obtained
by the Committee suggests
that those attempting to submit certain
of the electoral votes
regarded the need to provide
that material to Vice
President Pence as urgent."
The bigger question is
whether the various people
making the certificates
and submitting them acted
knowingly and willfully.
Some of those individuals
who signed their names
to fake certificates
said that they thought
that they'd only be used if
Trump prevailed in litigating
in their states, paving
the way for Trump's win
in those states to be certified,
making their fake certificates valid
and okay to submit to the
National Archives and to Congress.
But that's not the case with most
of the executive branch here.
Since Trump acting through
his co-conspirators,
like Eastman and Chesebro,
relied on the existence
of those fake electors
as a basis for asserting
that the Vice President could reject
or delay the certification
of the Biden electors.
The people who believed
that they were serving
as alternate electors
in case Trump prevailed
in court might not have known that Trump
and Eastman were
collecting the certificates
for another reason, to persuade Pence
to implement their illegal plan.
But the Committee alleges
that the higher ups,
including Donald Trump,
knew what they were doing
and personally participated in this plan.
Quote, "The evidence is clear
that President Trump
personally participated
in a scheme to have the Trump
electors meet, cast votes,
and send their votes to the
Joint Session of Congress
in several states that
Vice President Biden won,
and then his supporters
relied on the existence
of these fake electors
as part of their effort
to obstruct the Joint Session."
And to prove an overt acting
furtherance of a conspiracy,
the Committee relies on the testimony
of Republican National Committee
chairwoman Ronna McDaniel.
She told the Committee that Trump
and Eastman directly requested
that the RNC organized the effort
to have the fake electors
meet and cast their votes,
and that she complied with their request.
And then the fourth count
of the criminal referral is
for inciting, assisting,
or aiding an insurrection
in violation of 18 USC 2383.
Until the events of January 6th, 2021,
there had been no prosecutions
under Section 2383
since the Civil War.
The insurrection statute
was enacted in 1862
as a precursor to the
Emancipation Proclamation.
And there was an 1863
circuit court case that held
that the act was unconstitutional
because it punished the
same conduct as treason.
And treason was only applicable
if a foreign country levied
war against the United States.
Since 1863, the Supreme Court has implied
but has not yet ruled that it
would reject the insurrection
as an end run around treason argument.
President Trump was
acquitted of incitement
to insurrection in his
second impeachment trial,
but since this was not a judicial trial,
there's no double jeopardy problem.
However, it's not easy
to get a conviction under the statute
because it implicates the First Amendment.
The Committee relied on a
recent court opinion to assert
that Trump's speech wasn't
protected by the First Amendment.
In Thompson versus Trump, a
judge on the DC Circuit ruled
that the statements Trump made
during his Ellipse speech
before the riot, quote,
"Were plausibly words of
incitement not protected
by the First Amendment."
This was a civil case where 11 members
of the US House of Representatives
and two Capitol police officers
sued Trump seeking damages
for physical injuries
and emotional distress
from January 6th.
The court ruled that Trump
would not necessarily be able
to invoke presidential immunity
in defending the claim.
But you can imagine something
that is arguably political speech is going
to receive the highest amount
of First Amendment protection.
So we'll see how this one goes.
The Committee argues that
it doesn't need to prove
that Donald Trump was actually in contact
with the actual rioters
or that there was evidence
of an actual agreement
between the President
and the rioters.
Quote, "The President need
only have incited, assisted,
or aided and comforted those engaged
in violence or other lawless activity
in an effort to prevent
the peaceful transition
of the Presidency under our Constitution."
But as an interesting coda here,
although the Congressional
criminal referrals
carry no legal weight, Jack Smith,
who Attorney General
Merrick Garland appointed
as special counsel in charge
of looking into these crimes,
at least as it regards
Donald Trump and others
in that orbit, sent a letter
to the select Committee requesting
all the panel's materials
from the 18 month probe.
So the special prosecutor is
looking into the evidence,
if not the referrals themselves.
But if the DOJ picks up
the criminal referrals,
whether they convict on any
of these counts will largely depend
on whether they can prove
Trump's mental state.
And luckily, I made a video all about
whether Donald Trump has the
criminal intent necessary
for conviction, but you can only see it
with today's sponsor,
Curiosity Stream and Nebula.
Because on Nebula, my
videos always come out early
with zero ads.
And I release exclusive
content all the time,
like this video
that is exclusive about
Trump's mental state.
It was hard to make.
Some would say, "What mental state?"
Or an entire video about legal
stories that are not safe
for work because they're
too hot for YouTube,
as well as exclusive videos
like things people misunderstand
about the Constitution,
why NFTs are bad for creators.
And my first full-length documentary,
"Bad Law Words Good."
And tons more, all exclusive to Nebula.
Because Nebula is creator-owned
and creator-operated,
there's new exclusive content
released every single day.
In fact, Johnny Harris
just signed with Nebula
and you can see all of his
videos a week early only
on Nebula first.
And by the way, we've been
developing Nebula like crazy.
Nebula now has apps for
iOS, Android, Apple TV,
Roku, Fire TV, Android TV.
And it was recently nominated
for its second streaming award.
My fellow creators and I
really care about Nebula
and we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity Stream
because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries
and long-form educational
content on the internet.
They even have an entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries and crime.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the thousands
of titles on Curiosity Stream.
But the best way to get access to Nebula
and all this incredible content is
through the amazing Curiosity
Stream/Nebula bundle deal
with its current sale of 42% off.
That's less than $12 a year
to get access to both sites.
And to be clear, that Nebula
Subscription is not a trial,
it's free for as long as you're a member
of Curiosity Stream.
There just isn't a better deal
in streaming where you get
two great streaming sites
with content that you'll
actually watch all
for less than $12 for the entire year
at its current sales price.
And it's 42% off.
So, all you have to do is
click on the link that's
on screen right now or
down in the description
to get 42% off both Curiosity Stream
and get Nebula for free.
So just click now on the
link that's on screen
or down in the description.
It's a great way to
support educational content
and get tons of exclusive content
that you'll actually love.
So click right now.
And after that, click on
this playlist over here
for more Legal Eagle or
I'll see you in court.